professor Taylor congratulations on the
award how was the ceremony moving
special yeah and sort of extra special
because pear stromberg who presented me
with the award is an old friend so
personal touch yeah so does the
endowment effect apply to the Nobel
Prize as well is it worth more to you
today like six months ago well let's say
I'm not I'm not likely to give it up
well you know when I get my paycheck I
always buy champagne and this is not
just because I'm irrational it's also
because I'm irresponsible but do you do
that as well I mean behave irresponsibly
economically oh you know I'm pretty
irresponsible in most ways but you know
so what's the worst thing you do with
your money
usually the worst thing I do with my
money well I do like to play golf so is
there a lot of expensive equipment
there's expensive equipment and you know
belonging to a club but it's really
rational because it saves time that's
true well actually reading up on you and
reading up on your theories and your
experiments of course you say that man
is irrational but you also say the man
is good altruistic fair and that we base
our decisions on this so do you have
faith in mankind well I have more faith
in mankind than economists do generally
well more and less so I think people are
nicer than economists could give them
credit for and care more about their
fellow human beings but you know their
ability to figure out which mortgage is
best for them or to calculate how much
to save for retirement
they're not nearly as good at that as
economists give them credit for yeah
well it all started with the list about
and I quote weird people do so do
you still add to that list oh yeah I
just heard a story about an American
couple who went to Germany and bought
tickets to a very expensive concert just
when it was starting they realized it
was in fact a comedy not a concert they
don't speak a word of German they spent
the whole night there well professor
Thaler thank you so much and once again
congratulations and have a lovely
evening thank you very much